So you can say, well, it's awkward
kernel design at the heart or
the center or core of it.
What really goes into it?
What is included in the trusted
computing base when it is done
by using the security
kernel kind of an approach.
So we said, well, last one we're saying
everything that is necessary for
the mechanisms, that are necessary for
correct enforcement of security policies
we want to have in
the system should go there.
We know resources are implemented
using physical resources we have,
so any I/O that's necessary to access
your physical resources, primitive I/O
has to be handled in there, which
includes clocks, interrupt handling,
at least capturing the interrupt,
and being able to directly access
the hardware resources with whatever
capabilities that are necessary for it.
In memory, for example,
we said we have TLBs or
speeding up the address translation
process and things like that.
So who can manipulate those control
part of memory, somebody can use.
So that kind of stuff, if you're doing
manager access control, then there's
label checking, that the model is
going to rely on notion of labels and
making sure secret information
doesn't flow into an object that is
unclassified and things like that.
So that's part of your security policy
and the correct enforcement, of course,
has to be implemented
by the security kernel.
And direct access to hardware resources
and their manipulation, and support for
these various models for access
control we have has to be in that.
The other thing we did is
sort of virtualization.
One way we get sort of a complete
mediation, and you can bypass it,
is that untrusted code is,
has handles who worked with resources.
Unless we're talking
about capability systems.
So this virtualization, were putting
this mechanism going from virtual to
physical resources helps us isolate
the hardware from untrusted code.
It also allows us to do the separation